THAT'S JUDICIAL DECISION IS
ALMOST TOO SANE TO BE TRUE.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DOCUMENTS
REVEAL HOW NEARLY ALL OF FUSION
GPS TRANSMITTED MATERIAL FROM
THE TRUMP DOSSIER TO HER
HUSBAND.
A SENIOR DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR.
THAT FILLED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
PERCOLATED ALL THE WAY THROUGH
AND WAS USED TO TAINT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WITH BOGUS
ACCUSATIONS OF ESPIONAGE BEFORE
IT WAS SWORN IN.
TOM IS THE PRESIDENT OF JUDICIAL
WATCH.
THEY OBTAINED THOSE DOCUMENTS.
HE JOINS US NOW.
TOM, THIS NEXUS BETWEEN ONE
WOMAN WORKING FOR A GROUP THAT
IS WORKING FOR THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WHO IS MARRIED TO A
SENIOR FIGURE IN THE GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS BASICALLY A CLASSIC
BANANA REPUBLIC STUFF.
IT'S THE MERGER OF THE PARTY AND
THE STATE.
>> YES, BRUCE OHR IS TELLING THE
FBI, I GOT THIS INFORMATION.
LET'S INVESTIGATE THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
ELECTED.
HE BRINGS IN A FLASH DRIVE WITH
HIS WIFE'S MATERIAL ON IT.
STRIPPED FROM THAT MATERIAL IS
THE INFORMATION FUSION GPS FROM
THE HEADERS.
THEY WERE TRYING TO DISGUISE THE
MATERIAL.
WE GET THAT FROM THE FBI
INTERVIEW NOTES AND DOCUMENTS
DESCRIBED THE MATERIAL HE SENT
TO THE FBI.
IT INCLUDE A CHART.
PEOPLE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS
CHART.
IT'S CRAZY.
IT'S 80 NAMES.
SHE TRIES TO TIE ALL OF THEM TO
RUSSIA, TO TRUMP.
IT'S LIKE AN INSANE VERSION OF 6
DEGREES OF KEVIN BACON.
IF YOU SAW IT ON A WALL, YOU
WOULD SAY WHO IS THE CRAZY
PERSON WHO CREATED THIS?
THIS IS THE BASIS FOR THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION AND THE FACT THAT
THE SENIOR LEVELS OF THE DOJ AND
THE FBI WERE USING THIS MATERIAL
TO TARGET A SITTING PRESIDENT
TELLS YOU VOLUMES ABOUT THE
CORRUPTION BEHIND THE EFFORT TO
OVERTHROW HIM.
THIS IS INSANE.
>> A SIMPLE QUESTION.
YOU ASKED FOR ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
THE COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN BRUCE
OHR AND THIS IS MI-6 AGENT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AFTER HE WAS
GOTTEN RID OF BY THE FBI.
BRUCE OHR IS STILL HIS PAL.
HAS THERE EVER BEEN A U.S.
DOMESTIC PROCESS AS INTERFERED
WITH BY ONE FOREIGN NATIONAL AS
PERPETRATED BY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY AMERICANS
ARE NOT MAD ABOUT THAT.
>> YES, THE INVOLVEMENT OF HIS
FORMER COLLEAGUES IN THE UNITED
KINGOM.
AND THE AUSTRALIA GOVERNMENT
ASKED ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
THIS IS AN INTERNATIONAL
CONSPIRACY AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
OHR AND STEELE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER AND THEY HIRE THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN TO PUSH THIS
MATERIAL.
THE CLINTON GANG WERE FLOODING
THE ZONE:
THE DOJ, FBI, THE STATE AND THE
WIFE OF A SENIOR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL.